>>> WELL, NO END IN SIGHT FOR
SOARING GAS PRICES.
THE AVERAGE PRICE OF A GALLON
NOW WELL OVER $4 AS THE U.S.
EXPERIENCES ITS WORST BATTLE
WITH INFLATION IN DECADES.
>> I KNOW THAT FAMILIES ALL
ACROSS AMERICA ARE HURTING
BECAUSE OF INFLATION.
I WANT EVERY AMERICAN TO KNOW
THAT I'M TAKING INFLATION VERY
SERIOUSLY, AND IT'S MY TOP
DOMESTIC PRIORITY.
>> SO WE HAVE A LOT TO DISCUSS
WITH A MEMBER OF THE PRESIDENT'S
CABINET, TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY PETE BUTTIGIEG JOINS
US.
THANK YOU, SECRETARY.
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US THIS
EVENING.
GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
>> GOOD EVENING.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN CALLS
INFLATION HIS NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY.
IT IS AT A 40-YEAR HIGH.
WHAT DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
PLAN TO DO ABOUT IT?
AND PEOPLE DON'T WANT LONG-TERM
PLANS.
THEY WANT ACTION NOW.
>> WELL, THE PRESIDENT LAID OUT
A NUMBER OF SPECIFIC STEPS, MANY
OF THEM ALREADY UNDER WAY AND
MORE TO COME.
I THINK THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING ABOUT TODAY'S
MESSAGE, NOT JUST THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S SAYING IT'S A
PRIORITY, BUT HE'S MAKING CLEAR
WHAT WE'RE DOING ABOUT IT.
SOME OF IT IS THE MEASURES THAT
HE'S ALREADY TAKEN TO STABILIZE
OR HELP STABILIZE GLOBAL OIL
MARKETS, WHICH AFFECTS GAS
PRICES.
SOME OF IT'S ACTION WHICH HE HAS
ADVANCED IN CONGRESS TO DO
THINGS LIKE LOWER THE COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, CAP INSULIN
AT $35, LOWER THE COST OF CHILD
CARE, INTERNET ACCESS AND OTHER
MEASURES.
NOW, SOME OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
BLOCKED BY CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS, BUT OTHER MEASURES
ARE UNDER WAY AND ARE MAKING A
DIFFERENCE.
THEN YOU HAVE THE SUPPLY CHAIN
SIDE OF THINGS.
YOU KNOW, PART OF WHAT
CONTRIBUTES TO UPWARD PRESSURE
ON PRICES IS HIGH COSTS OF
SHIPPING.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE MAKING SOME OF
THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE
MAKING.
SOME OF THEM, SURE, THEY'RE
LONG-TERM, BUT SOME OF THEM ARE
STEPS THAT ARE OPERATING IN THE
SHORT TERM, PUSHING TOWARD 24/7
OPERATIONS AT OUR PORTS, WORKING
WITH TRUCK DRIVERS TO GET MORE
TRUCK DRIVERS TRAINED AND KEEP
THEM ON THE ROAD.
WORKING WITH RAIL COMPANIES TO
TRY TO GET THEIR FLUIDITY UP.
THIS IS AN ALL HANDS ON DECK
MOMENT AND THE PRESIDENT LAID
OUT TODAY A VERY CLEAR CONTRAST
BETWEEN A SPECIFIC SERIES OF
STEPS, POLICY STEPS, THAT HE'S
UNDERTAKING AND PROPOSING VERSUS
THE OTHER SIDE, WHICH LOVES TO
CRITICIZE ON THIS, BUT EITHER
HAS NO PLANS OR HAS PLANS THAT
DON'T MAKE ANY SENSE LIKE
RAISING TAXES ON THE MIDDLE
CLASS AND THE POOR JUST AT THE
MOMENT WHEN AMERICANS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THESE HIGH
PRICES.
>> LISTEN, I WANT TO ASK YOU
BECAUSE THERE'S ANOTHER
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR.
BUT JUST WHILE WE'RE ON THE
SUBJECT OF GAS PRICES, GAS
PRICES HAVE JUMPED TO A NEW
RECORD HIGH.
IF WE LOOK AT THIS CHART WE HAVE
UP RIGHT NOW, THEY'VE GONE WAY
UP OVER JUST THE LAST NINE
MONTHS.
HOW HIGH IS THIS GOING TO GO,
AND DOES THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE
ANY TOOLS TO CONTROL WHAT HAS
BEEN REALLY A SHOCK TO JUST
ABOUT EVERYONE'S POCKET?
>> WELL, THERE ARE SOME TOOLS.
LOOK, WHEN AN OIL COMPANY IS
DECIDING HOW MUCH TO CHARGE FOR
A GALLON OF GAS ANY GIVEN DAY,
OF COURSE THEY DON'T CALL THE
PRESIDENT TO CHECK.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE ACTIONS LIKE
THE RELEASE FROM THE STRATEGIC
PETROLEUM RESERVE -- AND BY THE
WAY, THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T JUST
DO THAT UNILATERALLY.
HE DID ONE OF THE THINGS HE
COMMITTED TO DO, WHICH IS RALLY
INTERNATIONAL PLAYERS, ALLIES,
AND PARTNERS TO DO THE SAME.
THAT HAD AN EFFECT.
WERE IT NOT FOR THAT, PRICES
WOULD BE HIGHER THAN THEY ARE
NOW.
THE TRUTH IS AS LONG AS WE ARE
DEPENDENT ON THESE KINDS OF
FOREIGN DICTATORS AND THE FUEL
THEY PRODUCE, WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE SEEING THESE ISSUES.
THAT'S WHY LONG-TERM WE'VE GOT
TO MAKE SURE WE REDUCE OUR
DEPENDENCE.
SHORT-TERM, THE PRESIDENT'S
TAKEN ACTIONS LIKE MAKING MORE
HOMEGROWN BIOFUELS AVAILABLE IN
THE NEAR TERM.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT ARE GOING
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE EVEN IF, WE
KNOW, AGAIN, THE GAS PRICE IS
SET BY GLOBAL PETROLEUM MARKETS,
NOT BY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE OTHER
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO THIS
UNEASE WITH THE ECONOMY THAT
AMERICANS ARE HAVING.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS BLAMING THE
PANDEMIC AND PUTIN'S WAR FOR
INFLATION.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THAT
$1.9 TRILLION AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN?
THE SAN FRANCISCO FEDERAL
RESERVE BANK CONCLUDED LAST
YEAR, SECRETARY, THAT THE
STIMULUS CONTRIBUTED TO
INFLATION.
SHOULDN'T AT LEAST PART OF THE
BLAME BE PLACED ON THAT?
>> LOOK, AT THAT TIME, THE
COUNTRY WAS FACING THE CONTINUED
RISK OF ECONOMIC COLLAPSE.
ACTION HAD TO BE TAKEN TO BRING
BACK THE ECONOMY, TO MAKE SURE
THAT AMERICANS HAD MORE MONEY IN
THEIR POCKETS, THAT JOBS THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN LOST PERHAPS
FOREVER WERE SAVED.
IT IS TRUE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE VERY LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE FEWER PEOPLE
ON UNEMPLOYMENT THAN WE'VE HAD,
I THINK, SINCE 1970.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, THAT DOES
CREATE PRESSURES IN LABOR
MARKETS.
BUT IF YOU CONSIDER THE
ALTERNATIVE, THE POSSIBILITY
THAT WE COULD HAVE SEEN THE KIND
OF ECONOMIC COLLAPSE THAT WAS A
VERY REAL RISK BEFORE THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN, THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THAT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
IT HAS SAVED COUNTLESS JOBS,
LIKELY MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
JOBS, AND IT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THE JOB CREATION
RECORD OF THIS PRESIDENT IN HIS
FIRST YEAR IS ONE THAT IS THE
MOST SWIFT CREATION OF JOBS IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> UNDERSTOOD.
BUT DID IT CONTRIBUTE TO
INFLATION AS ECONOMISTS SAY?
>> LOOK, I THINK THAT HISTORIANS
AND ECONOMISTS WILL BE DEBATING
THE EARLY 2020s AND WHAT
HAPPENED FOR MANY YEARS AND
DECADES.
BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE STILL LIVING
IN THAT MOMENT.
RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'VE GOT TO DO
IS FOCUS ON THE TOOLS THAT ARE
IN OUR HANDS THAT WILL ACTUALLY
HELP RIGHT NOW.
AND WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
COUNTERBALANCING THE EFFECTS OF
PUTIN INVADING A COUNTRY
OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU HAVE A MAJOR
OIL-PRODUCING COUNTRY GO TO WAR,
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE EFFECTS, OR
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DEALING WITH SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN DRIVEN BY THE
PANDEMIC, THERE ARE THINGS WE
ARE DOING.
RIGHT NOW THE PRESIDENT'S ASKING
FOR SUPPORT ON THIS, AND WHAT WE
SEE COMING OUT OF THE OTHER SIDE
IS CERTAINLY A DESIRE TO THROW
PUNCHES AND OFFER A LOT OF
CRITICISMS OVER THIS BUT VERY
LITTLE IN THE WAY OF ACTUAL
PLANS.
I MEAN RAISING TAXES ON THE POOR
AND THE MIDDLE CLASS, I SUPPOSE
THEY COULD ARGUE THAT COULD
SOMEHOW REDUCE INFLATION, BUT
THAT WOULD BE A TERRIBLE,
TERRIBLE WAY TO DO IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT WENT ON OFFENSE
AGAINST THE GOP, ATTACKING
THEIR, QUOTE, ULTRA MAGA
POLICIES.
THEN HE SAYS THIS.
WATCH.
>> I UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION,
BUT THE FACT IS CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS -- NOT ALL OF
THEM -- BUT THE MAGA REPUBLICANS
ARE COUNTING ON YOU TO BE AS
FRUSTRATED BY THE PACE OF
PROGRESS WHICH THEY HAVE
EVERYTHING -- THEY'VE DONE
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO SLOW
DOWN, THAT YOU WILL HAND POWER
OVER TO THEM SO THEY CAN ENACT
THEIR EXTREME AGENDA.
>> SO PRESIDENT BIDEN REPEATEDLY
HAMMERING MAGA REPUBLICANS IN
HIS SPEECH THERE, BUT AMERICANS
ARE FEELING THE PINCH NOW WHILE
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS IN CHARGE.
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE HOUSE.
THEY CONTROL THE SENATE.
DOES THAT MESSAGE REALLY WORK
NOW TO SAY THE OTHER GUYS WILL
BE WORSE?
>> WELL, I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND THE TWO VERY
DIFFERENT APPROACHES THAT EXIST
HERE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS LAID OUT A
SPECIFIC POLICY PROGRAM AND A
SPECIFIC APPROACH, ACTIONS THAT
ARE UNDER WAY, MORE THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO AND ARE DOING THAT ARE
GOING TO HELP LOWER THOSE COSTS
THAT AMERICANS ARE FACING.
THE OTHER SIDE IS OFFERING
PROPOSALS LIKE RAISING TAXES ON
THE POOR AND THE MIDDLE CLASS,
PROPOSALS LIKE GETTING RID OF
MEDICARE AND SOCIAL SECURITY
EVERY FIVE YEARS UNLESS CONGRESS
RECREATES THEM, THINGS THAT ARE
COMPLETELY OUT OF STEP WITH
WHAT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE HERE.
I DO THINK ANYTIME SOMEBODY
WANTS TO THROW STONES AND
CRITICIZE -- AND OF COURSE
THEY'RE GOING TO CRITICIZE
WHOEVER IS IN CHARGE -- THAT
THEY BE CHALLENGED TO EXPLAIN
WHAT THEY WOULD DO DIFFERENTLY,
WHAT THEY WOULD DO TO MAKE IT
ANY BETTER, WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT GAS PRICES,
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
INFLATION OR ANY OF THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT ARE FEROCIOUS ISSUES
IN OUR ECONOMY, BUT THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS SQUARELY FACING AND
LEADING THIS COUNTRY TO CONTEND
WITH BECAUSE HE KNOWS HOW MUCH
OF AN IMPACT IT IS ON FAMILIES,
BECAUSE HE KNOWS THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE ARE
FEELING AT THE KITCHEN TABLE,
FEELING AT THE PUMP.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED NOT
NAME-CALLING, NOT PERSONAL
ATTACKS LIKE WHAT WE SAW FROM
SENATOR SCOTT TODAY, BUT
SPECIFIC POLICY AGENDAS.
AND OURS, FRANKLY, IS JUST MORE
CLEAR, MORE COGENT, AND IT'S
GOING TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL.
>> SECRETARY, I DO WANT TO ASK
YOU ABOUT THE SUPREME COURT'S
UPCOMING ABORTION DECISION WHERE
IT APPEARS THAT ROE V. WADE MAY
BE OVERTURNED.
THERE WILL BE IMMEDIATE
CONSEQUENCES FOR WOMEN AND
FAMILIES.
WHAT ABOUT OTHER RIGHTS LIKE
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE?
COULD THAT BE NEXT?
>> WELL, I THINK RIGHT NOW THE
FOCUS RIGHTLY IS ON WOMEN AND
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
AND I WILL SAY, YOU KNOW, FOR
ALL OF MY LIFE AND ALL OF MODERN
AMERICAN HISTORY, I THINK THE
DIRECTION THAT WE'VE BEEN GOING
IN AS A COUNTRY, THE DIRECTION
THAT THE CONSTITUTION HAS LED US
TO IN THE SUPREME COURT, HAS
BEEN ONE OF EXPANDING RIGHTS,
HAS BEEN ONE OF EXPANDING
FREEDOMS.
AND SUDDENLY THIS DECISION, IF
THIS IS WHAT THE DECISION WILL
BE, REPRESENTS A RETREAT FROM
THAT.
THE BIG QUESTION IS DID WE LIVE
TO SEE THE HIGH WATER MARK OF
FREEDOM IN THIS COUNTRY AND NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK AT THE
EXPENSE OF WOMEN WHO HAVE FOR
THE LAST 50 YEARS BEEN TRUSTED
TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR OWN HEALTH, OR ARE WE
GOING TO PUSH FORWARD?
BUT THERE ARE, OF COURSE, A LOT
OF OTHER AMERICANS WHO ARE
WONDERING WHETHER THEIR RIGHTS
AND FREEDOMS MIGHT BE NEXT.
AND NEEDLESS TO SAY, SAME-SEX
MARRIAGE IS AN EXAMPLE OF A
FREEDOM, OF A RIGHT THAT WAS
EXPANDED, THAT WAS EXPANDED
BECAUSE IT WAS DEEMED BY THE
SUPREME COURT TO BE SOMETHING
THAT THE CONSTITUTION PROTECTS,
AND NOW YOU'VE GOT A SUPREME
COURT THAT, AGAIN, IF THIS MEMO
TURNS INTO A DECISION, APPEARS
TO HAVE VERY LITTLE REGARD FOR
PRECEDENT.
AND I'M NOT COMFORTED BY ANY OF
THE REASSURANCES THAT THAT WOULD
NOT LEAD TO OTHER FREEDO